ام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم جاءت مباراه الفريق الوطني
المصري لكره القدم امام منتخب غانا في
تصفيات كاس العالم لتضيف بعدا جديدا ل
حاله الانقسام السياسي في مصر لكنه هذه
المره بنكهه رياضيه نتوقف مع هذا الموضوع
لنناقشه في محورين
هل ادى الانقسام السياسي في مصر الى
انقسام رياضي اتجاه المنتخب الوطني
وهل يمكن ان ينجح الاستخدام السياسي
للاحداث الرياضيه اثناء الازمات
[موسيقى]
ليست هذه المره الاولى التي يتعرض فيها
منتخب مصر لكره القدم للهزيمه وليست المره
الاولى التي يتحكم فيها المصريون على
احوالهم بطرق مبتكره تعكس ما يتمتعون به
من روح فكاهه لكن هذه المره تحكمت السياسه
بشكل لافت في تحديد ردود الفعل وكانت
المباراه ونتيجتها اقوى مثل لظاهره
الاستخدام السياسي للاحداث الرياضيه
لم تفلح الساحره المستديره في جسر هوه
السياسيه بين المصريين مباراه مصر وغانا
الحاسمه في التاهل لمونديال الفين واربعه
عشر سددت اليها سهام السياسه من قبل ان
تبدا وحتى بلغت نهايتها المؤلمه للمنتخب
المصري على الاقل تعود المصريون على مر
عقود طرح همومهم و خلافاتهم على اعتاب
المستطيل الاخضر خاصه اذا كان المنتخب
الوطني هو اللاعب وفي مباراه قد تقرب حل
ما يداعب خيال الكثيرين من ربع قرن
لكن هذه المره كانت السياسه للرياضه صاحبه
الحظ الاوفر من الحضور حتى والشان كروي
بحث وبين المباراه يكرس وزير الرياضه في
الحكومه المؤقته هذا المعنى وبالتاكيد ان
شاء الله
يعني انتشار الرياضي بطعم الزياده
كيف لا واعلام المصريين كغيره اعتاد اهداء
انتصارات الكره لفخامه الرئيس او من يقوم
مقامه ما يعني بحسب معارضي النظام القائم
تسجيل هدف لصالح سلطه انقلبت على الشرعيه
وما يدل ذلك منصبه اتصالات المتوقعه لا
تتناسب مع احزان الاف الاسر التي فقدت
ابنائها في العيد بين قتيل و معتقل بل ان
بعضهم استدعى من قريب الذاكره نشوه اسره
الحكم على وقع مباراه كره بينما كانت
اسماك البحر تنهش جثه غرق عباره السلام
عام الفين وسته حتى ان نفرا من هذا البعض
وصفوا كره القدم با فين الشعوب بينما تمنى
الفوز مؤيدوا خارطه الطريق لكسر احباط
يحدث بحياه المصريين يرد شانه برايهم الى
رواسب عهد مرسي وفعل انصاره في الشارع بعد
المباراه وعلى عاده المصريين في احلك
الظروف فجر فضول انقلاب انهار السخريه
والتهكم مما اعتبروه شؤم القائمين على امر
البلاد ناقد رياضي منهم اكد على الاستغلال
السياسي للحدث من طرف السلطات وجهان لعمله
واحده في نوفمبر 2009 حول جمال مبارك
تحويل فوز مصر على الجزائر والتاهل لكاس
العالم للدعايه سياسيه خسرنا وخرجنا وفي
اكتوبر الفين وثلاثه عشر حاول الانقلاب
تحويل فوز مصر علي غانا والتاهل لكاس
العالم لدعايه سياسيه وخسرنا وخرجنا وسواء
على المصريين احرم نهائيات كاس العالم
تبقى تداعيات لاستقطاب الح اه مشكلات ترجع
وحلولا اعمق كثير من مداواه خساره في
مباراه كره
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفينا في
الاستوديو الاستاذ وائل قنديل الكاتب
الصحفي الاستاذ ياسر الهواري عضو جبهه
الانقاذ مرحبا بكم وائل يقال انه ليس من
الحكمه الشباب في نتيجه مباراه المنتخب
الوطني واظهار هذه الشماته في وقت يحزن
كثير من المصريين على هذه النتيجه هذا لا
يكسب انصار التحالف الوطني لدعم الشرعيه
ورفض الخلاف بل معارضي الانقلاب لا يفقدهم
انصار ا اولا يكسبهم انصار اجدد انما
يفقدهم تعاطف مع من ربما كانوا يتعاطفون
معه اسمح لي ان هذا النوع من التوظيف
للخساره والتوظيف السياسي الخساره بانها
النوع من التنطع الرياضي لا احد ي يشمل في
مصر ولا احد ي يشمل في منتخب مصر الناس
فقدت قارنت بين اوضاع اوضاع الذي جرى في
هذه المباراه ان هناك حاله فشل في منظومه
فشل كامله ادت الى هذه الخساره انا لست
ممن يعتبرون او يربطون بين الهويه الوطنيه
وبين كره القدم انا يعني اتفق كثيرا مع
الفيلسوف العربي الكبير الطيب زين ي لما
قال انه النظام الرسمي العربي سحب ال
السياسه وكرس كره القدم بتفاهتها اه معيار
تقدم الامم او الشعوب لا يقاس ام لا بكره
القدم وهذا النوع من الاستثمار لكره القدم
سياسيا دائما يرتبط بالانظمه القمعيه
المستبده رايناه مع حسني مبارك طوال
ثلاثين عاما وكان ال ال ال الفريق القومي
يستخدم يعني وفقا لما ورد في المقدمه
الشعوب يستخدم في الالهاء وفي صرف الناس
هل تعلم ان في مصر اليوم الامس في نفس
توقيت المباراه كارثه انهيار الجسر دمرت
مئات المنازل واغرقت مئات الافدنه
وتسببت في نفوق ما شيء او تشرين في الموقف
الاسرائيلي لم يلتفت له هم يريدون استثمار
هذه الخساره ايضا لصالحهم الذي جرى
باختصار شديد انما مجموعه هم الذين اولا
تحدثوا عن الربط بين هذه المباراه وبين ما
يسمى بثلاثين
الاعلام الانقلابي الرسمي وغير الرسمي بل
ان وزير الرياضه بل ان مقدم البرامج
الرياضيه استبقوا هذه المباراه وكان مذهبه
الى معركه حربيه اه انتصار مصر فيها يعني
انتصارا سياسيا و ثقافيا و مجتمعين اذن
لماذا تعتبر ان الا توافق على الشمال
هناك شماته في القتله هناك شراكه في الذين
قتلوا سته الاف مصري وارادوا ان من
المصريين ان يتفقوا لهم اذا فاز وفي هذه
المباراه هل تنكر ان هناك من المصريين من
كان يدعو ان تفوز هناك كثير من المصريين
بالفعل كانوا يتمنون هزيمه المسلك الطبيعي
طبيعيا ولكن هل المسلك الطبيعي ايضا ان
يحاسب الناس على مشاعرهم عن مباراه كره
القدم ولا احاسب على مجزره ومقتل يعني
لماذا اهتم كثيرا بمشاعر الناس في خساره
مهارات كره القدم و لا اهتم بهذه المشاعر
وهي تنتفض واحد حزنا على استشهاد اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف في رابعه العدويه فقط واكثر من
خمسه الاف على مدار الشهور الماضيه منذ
ثلاثين ب ياسر الهواري او ليس النظام
القائم والذي استدعى السياسه في مباراه
كره القدم بالاساس الاعلى استمعت الى ما
قاله وزير الشباب والرياضه اه عن ان هذا
ال ال الفوز اذا تحقق سيكون فوزا بطعم
سياسي يعني اه اه او ليس هذا هو الذي اراد
ان يجامل صاحبه بها الشباب عنهم بقتلهم هو
يعني الحقيقه ان ما يعني انا موافق على
استمرار النهج اللي كان موجود من من عهد
مبارك ما قبل العدو وظيفه بشويه مع الكلام
اللي انه الاستاذ انه نوع من انواع توظيف
لكره القدم في السياسه انه يعني في الاول
في الاخره ديكور يعني ما ذكر يعني ما هواش
يعني مش معركه حربيه ولا معركه التنميه
ولا معارك اقتصاديه ولا حاجه تخلي العالم
بتعيش ولكن ال الحقيقه اذا كان وزير
الرياضه اخطاء فهو استمر على المنهج
القديم مغير شي حاجه يعني ما حقيقه ما
عنده جديده والحقيقه انه انا كنت باسمع
الخطاب المناسبه في وجود جماعه الاخوان
يعني يعني في اللحظه اللي كانوا المنتخب
المصري كان فيه كان بيوصل وبياخذ خطواتنا
حول العالم كان بيقولوا انه اه والله اذا
مصر توصل كاس العالم اخيرا بفضل الحكم
جماعات الاخوان انا التوظيف اراده لم توقف
يعني طول طول الاسمين اللي فاتت لم يتوقف
ابدا مثل هذا النوع من انواع الممارسه لكن
الحقيقه هنا اللي انا بالنسبه لي غريب
شويه هو استمرار جماعه الاخوان او
المنتمين لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين في خط
الراس في الحائط والعناد مع ال بقيه
المصريين انا بقول بقيه المسلمين في ولايه
ان تبت الاخوه المصريين بقيه المفاصل ان
بشكل كامل العالم المصريين يعني مثلا انه
اذا الاخوان في هزيمه مصر مبارح
منتخب يعني لا منتخب عادل منصور ولا منتخب
حازم اللبنانيه ولا منتخب السياسي منتخب
مصر
الموضوع بشكل عملي الزاي ان تبتسم بتشمل
في ال ال الاسم اللي تحطوا بيلعب
وتظهر يعني يعني محاولتك للاغاثه الاخرين
انما يعني
ثلاثه وعشرين سنه
والانتصار السياسه
دكتور عبد الغني
يقولون يكفي يكفي ان ينظر اللاعبون الى ال
الفريق عبد الفتاح السيسي سيتحقق الفوز
عندما يكون الخطاب السبب في الاعلام
المصري بهذه الصوره هل تلوم على معارضه
السياسي ان يكونوا طبعا اه يعني
اللي بالطريق هو اصلا لم يتوقف على كل مده
ايام مبارك وايام
وال وال وال فترات يعني هو موقف ال
الاستمرار لكن انا بتكلم هنا انا عايز
فكره بحاجه انه يمشي اول مره ال الاخوان
يظهروا شابتها في هزيمه المصري يعني فكرك
خمسه يونيو اللي فات و وشوف صفحات الاخوان
كانت
هزيمه يونيو اللي هي هزيمه النصر ومعتبرين
الهزيمه جمال عبد الناصر الناصر اللي
انتصر عليهم في يوم من الايام هما بيردوا
له الجميل دخلت في انهم يزور الشمال هزيمه
للشعب العربي كله مش يعني
الناس كانت هزيمه مصر وهذه العرقله وجماعه
الاخوان اظهرت الشماته في هذه ميتين وكانت
الحقيقه انه هي يعني انا بقول انه ما فيش
حد احتفل بهزيمه يونيو في العالم كله الا
الاسرائيليين والاخوان يعني ما حدش يحتفل
باليوم اللي
من الشعب
سته اكتوبر اللي فات وانا
الجيش الموصل الجيش لمصر كلها مع ذلك نزل
الاخوان كانوا مصرين على
مباراه كره القدم
المقارنه بين هزيمه في المعركه العسكريه
وبين ما تشي كره قدم لمجموعه من اللاعبين
يعني اه لا تجوز على الاطلاق
وان كان فهو مرفوض طبعا الشيء بس الفت الى
ان ال
الاسرائيليين ايضا احتفلوا بما يسمى
الثلاثين وفرحوا به كثيرا يعني هم اعداء
من التاريخيه انا اعود الى جوهر المساله
واسمح لي انه دائما في النظم القمعيه
الاستبداديه تستخدم كره القدم ت تذكر جيدا
ان جورج بوش هذا القاتل بعد مغادره في ال
بغداد في الفين وثلاثه في الدوره المبيع
فئاتنا اه ركبو قفز فوق بعض الانجازات
الرياضيه للبعثه العراقيه عندما قال ما
كان العراقيون ليحققوا هذه النتائج لولا
انهم تنسوا الحريه على يد الغزو الامريكي
للعراق في الفين وثلاثه معمر القذافي مثلا
كان اه اه كره القدم ويقول انها غير
ديمقراطيه لان اثنين وعشرين دائره فقط هم
الذين يلعبون هذه هي العقليه التي تحكم
الانقلابيين في مصر يعني هم هم يكرهون
دائما الديمقراطيه الشفافه كره القدم
ممارسه كره القدم هي نوع من ممارسه
الديمقراطيه الشفافه الاداء على اعين
الجماهير على اعين الملايين
النتائج اه اه لا يستطيع احد ان يتلاعب
فيها قوانين اللعبه لا يستطيع احد ان
يستخدم
دستوريا او يستخدم نفوذا ويغير قوانين
اللعبه اثناء المباراه وبالتالي الحساب
على هذا الاداء هم دائما يرفضون مثل هذه
الديمقراطيه هم دائما يلجؤون الى فكره
التزييف تزييف الحشود يعني هل كان من من
المطلوب ان ياتوا ب ثلاثه وثلاثين مليون
متمرد عشان يهزمه مثلا
اعتادوا على هذا النوع من المنافسات لا
يريدون منافسات وفقا لقواعد ديمقراطيه
حقيقيه اليس هذا تحميل فوق
الطبيعي لمباراه اطلاقا يعني عندما ترى
هذا المؤتمر
وانا لا ارى اي مبرر لان يكون هناك ما تم
قومي في مصر على انها فشلت في هذا هو يعني
هي دائما دعنا نعود الى مثلا البرازيلي
عندما كانت سيده كره القدم على مستوى
العالم كله كانت دوله ومنهار اقتصاديا
نقبل هذه التجربه العظيمه في التصنيع
والتنميه عندما دخلت ال البرازيل على خط
الدول الصناعيه الكبرى واحدثت تنميه خفت
الاهتمام وهذا التعلق الطفوله بكره القدم
يعني لم نسمع عن من قد برازيلي كبير اه اه
في السنوات الماضيه ومع ذلك ليس هناك
كارثه في البرازيل اليابان هذه الدوله
العظيمه هي دوله صغيره جدا على خارطه كره
القدم الصين كذلك فقط في الدول الفاشله
سياسيا واقتصاديا وتنمويا هم الذين
يتعلقون ب اقدام اللاعبين
يعني انا اخطر في الخيط من هذه الملاحظه
يعني اذا كان لديك اه ولا ابنك اه مراسيم
في كل المواد في الكيمياء والفيزياء
والرياضيات وكل ال ما دراسه فيها ودرجته
دون المستوى بكثير وهو فالح فقط في لعبه
او في ماده الالعاب التي لا تضاف اصلا
للمجموعه هل ينبغي ان احزن كثيرا اذا رسب
في هذه الماده واستكمل اه باقي مظاهر
الرسوم اه او حتى اهل ينبغي ان افرح كثيرا
اذا ما حقق اعلى الدرجات في هذه الماده
اطلاق
في اي وجه من الوجوه
الامه ال التي تفرح جدا للوصول الى كاس
العالم او تحسن جدا الى خساره مباراه بهذه
الصوره في اي وجه من الوجوه متطوره
ومتقدمه تشوف هي الموضوع الموضوع ليه لانه
انت تسالني عن انا شخصيا
بعد تسعين الحكم
يتم نخلص والمساله بالنسبه لمساله عليه
جدا لكن احسن بردو انه المصري شعب غالبين
او شعبها البيت
يعني ما عندوش مثلا وسائل الرفاهيه اللي
موجوده عندنا اوروبا وامريكا ولا ولا حتى
الخليج العربيه ولكن لم تكن ومش عارف ايه
عموما يعني ولكن الشعب المصري ال بين ال
يعني اقل حاجه
كل حاجه ومع ذلك احنا بنقول انه لا يجب
تحميل الموضوع اكبر
ماتش كوره وانه انت فيه عندك في الاخر كل
ال ال المنظمات انت عندك ما فيش عندك دوري
بتلعب فيه بالك ثلاث سنين ما يعني بدي كان
متوقع انه هو شيء طبيعي انت بتلعب مع اقوى
منتخبه افريقيا وفي ظروفها كانت ظروف صعبه
جدا ومستوى الغريب
غريب من المصريين يحسنوا على متشكر
غريب انه يبقى فيه اخر من المصريين فرحه
لهذه ال هيدي ال هذه الحاجه الغريبه يعني
انا انا مش لاقي مبرر الحقيقه ان الاخوان
يفرحوا في هزيمه منتخب مصر لكره القدم وفي
هزيمه سبعه وستين ويقول
عليكم الفرحه
على هذه الملاحظه احد اه او مشاكل بعضها
قارب احد القتلى مؤخرا انه اثناء الجنازات
ي لدى مروره مرور الجنازه و جثمان الفقيد
اه اه الى جوار اه جيران هذا ال ال الشخص
المتوفى اذا بيهم يعني اه يعلون صوته
المذياع بالميه تسلم الايادي نكايه في هذا
هذا اليوم على اهل على اهل هذا القتيل
وهناك بالمناسبه مئات او الاف القتلى
الذين سقطوا مؤخرا والذين ربما لا يلام
على سلوكهم انهم اه اه يعني اه شعروا به
اداره او الناس من حولهم فرحين بمباراه
كره القدم واهل وهم دمائهم
لا انا بس عشان في حاجه لازم الناس تعرفها
في انه هاي طبعا الغير طبيعي انه انت تبقى
فيه بغض النظر مين وانت تعلم او تعليق او
تظهر حتى فرحك او حتى انه عدم عدم التراث
حرمه المريضتين انا باعتقد انه نوع من
انواع المرض النفسي زي بالضبط اللي يشمت
فى هزيمه بلده في اي مجال من المجالات
الاثنين اللي كان بالنسبه لي انا بس محتاج
انا اذكر الناس بانه اثناء القصف الالماني
على اه مدن وضواحي انجلترا كان الحفلات
الراقصه تتوقف وكان العمل لا يتوقف وكانت
الحضارات المدينه الموسيقى لا تتوقف كانت
الامور الحياه الطبيعيه ماشي مش مش طبيعي
انه انت يبقى عندك ظروف سياسيه او حقيقه
بعد الفاصل الكثير نناقش وبعده مشاهدينا
الاعزاء ان كان بامكان الرياضه المصريه ان
تصلح ما افسدته السياسه في البلاد ارجو ان
تبقوا معنا
ام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش اثر الانقسام السياسي في مصر على
ردود الفعل بعد هزيمه فريقها من قبل الان
فساد واي القنديل اذا كانت هذه المناسبه
قد اسهمت في كل المناسبات الاخرى عقب
الثالث من يوليو في تكريس حاله الانقسام
في مصر على هذا النحو هل تعتقد انه يمكن
بصوره ما ان تتحول المناسبات فنيه مناسبات
رياضيه مثل هذه
السابع الحاصل في المجتمع المصري بل
اختصاص والعداله مستحيل الانقسام اصلا هذه
المباراه لم تساهم في تعميق الانقسام
الانقسام قائم منذ ان قتل النظام الرسمي
المصري الاف المصريين في مجازر شاهد بها
العالم كله
وبالتالي هذه لم تصنع الانقسام عندما اه
اه اه اولا انا بدات بان الذي وصف هذه
المباراه سياسيا هذا النظام هذا الفريق
ذهب الى المباراه يعني هو فريق الامه
مهزومه اخلاقيا هذه الامه التي قتل فيها
هذا العدد الهائل وكان فيها بعض الناس
يعني يتعاملون بالعنصريه ويريدون اباده
البعض الاخر من المصريين كيف لها ان تنتصر
يعني انت لو ترى ان اللاعبين يعني فكره
الحافز اللاعبون ذهبوا الى هذه المباراه
وهم يدركون انهم لا يمثلون كل الشعب
المصري للاسف الشديد هذا الذي صنع اه هو
النظام السياسي الرسمي اللاعبون ذاهبون في
انتصار يعني عندما يكون اللاعب ويرى هذه
الشعارات الرابع الادويه في المباريات
المنتخب الغالي هذا يعني هذه هزيمه حضاريه
في الحقيقه قبل ان تكون هزيمه اه اه في
مباراه كره قدم وبالتالي اذا اردنا ان
نتحدث عن
استثمار ال الرياضه في اعاده اللحمه
الوطنيه وما الى ذلك لابد ان يصدق
هذا الامر خطوه كثيره للغايه اولها اقامه
العدل في مصر اولها القصاص للشهداء
ومحاسبه القتله كيف ليس ليس من الحكمه
الاسراف في ابداء رد الفعل حتى لو كان
المرء مظلوما يعني ولي القتيل له سلطان
ان لا يسرف في القتل لا نطالب بالعبد في
نهايه المطاف جرب ان ت ان يكون لك شهيد او
قتيل على يد هذا النظام
واسمح لي اسالك عن مشاعرك عن خساره في
مباراه كره القدم يعني احنا ايهما اكثر
يعني هل ستجلس اللي تبكي على منطقه منتخب
الفريق عبد الفتاح السيسي اه
في نظام حسني مبارك وحتى الان دائما كان
بيتقال يعني اسعار زي ما قال الرئيس
منتخبنا كويس هذا منتخب النظام الحاكم
وهذا المباريات تغير لو كانت مصر قد فازت
في هذه المباراه كان سيقال ان ابناء
السياسيه نجحوا في الوصول الى عندما حصل
الفريق سيقال انه منتخب مصر فلا تشمتوه في
مصر ربما كان هذا مثل كان معتادا من
الاعلام المصريه فى عهد مبارك وربما كان
مثلا متوقعا في هذا او ثلاثه كل العهود
يعني لم يتم يعني على المصدر او الموتور
او الذي قتل القريبه او اعتقل او قبل
العيد ب ب غير ابيه او اخيه اه مغاير في
السجون او مغيب من قبل ال الموت هل تلومه
على انه اه يعني يستعجب اللي فرح هؤلاء
هؤلاء الجديده على مباراه كره قدم عزمهم
على القتلى ما هو المشكله لانه انا قلتها
في ال في هزيمه وستين ما كانش فيه ايامها
لقتل وبالمناسبه عدد قتلى بتزيد يعني انا
انا انا في الحلقه النهار ده سمعت ثلاثه
الاف وسبعمائه وسته ثلاثه وخمسه يعني
الارقام عم بتزيد بشكلها في الحلقه اللي
جايه في الحلقه اللي جايه
يعني ولا واحد يستهل ان احنا نحضر عليكم
بقول لك انه ال ال الم اظهار الشماته ما
كانتش الازهر الشفافيه هزيمه منتخب كره
القدم لانه بينتمي سياسيا الى مش عارف
العدل منصور والبريه والهزيمه هذه ونصف
وهم مش موجودين في السلطه يبقى كل كل ما
يحدث في مصر ضدهم وبالتالي اظهار الشماته
الصوره بموضوعيه
شايف ان الموضوع
القضيه
اي ان هناك اناس لهم قتلى
طبعا لانه انت هنا الطرف اللي تم تنفيذها
هو اسمه مصر ولا حد سياسي انا مستعد انه
احنا
يعني يعني المشكله مع النظام اللي موجود
يبقى فيه عندنا مشكله مع احد مع وزير
الداخليه مع وزير الدفاع ان كان مع رئيس
الجمهوريه مع رئيس وزراء كيان الموضوع لكن
انا عندي مشكله مع اسمه مصريه الا اذا انا
مش مقتنع فعلا يعني انت فعلا فكره الدوله
المصريه كمان تخير المواطن البسيط
في حاجه الى ترتسم على شفاه يعني هل هل
يستكثر هذا الفريق على المواطن البسيط
الذي ربما ليس له في السياسه ولم يقتل
بهذه احد ان يسعد او يفرح لان بلاده مثلا
حقيقه انتصار الرياضي من العار الحضاري
على مصر ان تختزل الدوله المصريه في كره
القدم في مباراه كره القدم يعني اذا خسرت
مصر في كره قدم في مصر
واذا فازت نصف هذا كلام سخيف وهذا كلام هو
يعني ديدا السلطات المستبده الفاسده
الفاشله انت صرف الانظار دائما بمثل هذه
الاشياء مباراه كره قدم مسابقه نجم العرب
سوبر استار معرفش في اه في بوكر
هذا الامر
لدى الهزيمه او انتصار فبكل اهتماماتك هذا
الامر برمته التعامل الامثل ال يعني اقيم
الدنيا واعطتها امام هذا الفرح وامام هذا
الحزب الشعب الذي مباراه كره القدم في
نهايه المطاف لم تنقل مصر الى مصاف الدول
الكبرى والمتقدمه اذا فازت ولن تهوي بها
الى الحضيض اكثر مما هي اذا خسر لابد ان
نعقد المساله هذا هو المطلوب
انا انا شايف انه هي في النهايه هو مذكور
احنا بعد ثلاثه وعشرين سنه الجديد يعني ما
حصل جديده بالنسبه مساله انه الناس بتظهر
الشماليه على هذه المنطقه مصر او بتظهر
الفرح وتنص به الى النظام في حاله الفوز
انا باعتقد النداء نوع من انواع الفشل
وتردي الحضور يعني انا ما سالت ان احنا
او او او اي حاجه الى علاقه بالشؤون الشكل
بس ال ال عتاب الوحيد في العتاب الوحيد
انك لا تظهر الشماته فى اسم مصر المكان
يعني حد يعني اي حاجه الاستوديو عضو جبهه
الانقاذ
شكرا جزيلا لك اشكرك ذلك ضيفنا انتصر
القنديل الكاتب والصحفي اشكركم مشاهدينا
على حسن المتابعه بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
تعالى في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
السلام عليكم
ام
[موسيقى]